[Laughter]
so every once in a while i run out of
ideas never happens actually yeah and i
agree
but then when it does happen i need a
side pick me up oh of course of course
you're always there giving me the
freshest the bestest so i asked you to
give me the life you lose challenge yeah
you pipe this up real bad
you're like you know you're gonna you're
gonna die you're gonna [ __ ] yourself
believe me it's guaranteed i can make
you laugh i guarantee you that all right
well i guess challenge accepted yeah oh
yeah let's go
now after being told that he won the
lottery jackpot a western cape man peed
all over the office floor of his boss of
over 23 years and proceeded to take a
dump
on his boss's office desk before
quitting his job on friday morning now
when he went to go claim his winnings
this morning he found that he had never
won anything
oh god
it's my apology
i can't
what is it cringe
i can't lie with the first one get out
of here yeah are you actually laughing
no i didn't lie i did not you did not
good night i could literally hear you
struggling that is so funny though
it gets even better like it's going to
be you just showing up one day
listen towards the end just play it wait
it gets worse it gets worse
oh well the 42 year old man who is now
unemployed
now faces charges of vandalism and other
related criminal challenges
probably say what goes around
exactly
what [ __ ] got arrested he's like
getting charged
[Music]
i mean that's awesome
all right so next one i can't believe
you said this to me as a british as a
british of course how dare you
dude i gotta say like i love this meme
so much but and i want to send it to
like people but i'm always like can i
are people that you can you can you
can't believe it can i i don't know
no british person gives a [ __ ] about the
duke brother
i'm gonna be factual with you
oh that makes it so funny oh god
okay let's watch it
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait the way
the tide the title of this is bbc's
awkward announcement
of of the death of the
royal um
duke yes
buckingham palace has announced the
death of his royal highness the duke of
edinburgh
[Music]
dude it goes so hard
[Laughter]
do you think that was intentional i mean
they must have been they surely didn't
give a [ __ ] they're like all right we
got to do this read might as well do it
at the beat
change look let's go
that's their job anyway right to make
things smooth like that i felt like the
person that did that just got a huge
laugh as soon as this is happening i can
imagine half the studio just dying no i
don't think they left i think they just
vibed hard as [ __ ]
that's so [ __ ] hard
god damn also all bra ish i apologize
for side
so you take responsibility for
cancellation right these are your clips
can you say that to the camera oh no
absolutely as i said like we don't
endorse it's just purely for comedic
purposes all right okay that covers us
legally perfect i was trying to record
when my grandma felt
this is making me laugh i've seen these
beams like a hundred times that is not
real that is not real that is not real
bro we
[ __ ]
god damn it
every time i laugh you get a race time
how about that
i'm doing good
is it real i can't tell and that makes
it so [ __ ] funny
holy [ __ ] oh god all right all right we
gotta get through this you have so many
clips dude jesus
this is two months worth of clips that
i've just been saying
that's good i need to start doing that
[Music]
i really hate when people tell me like
oh your car is not reliable but you
don't even have a heart
[Music]
oh god
it's a little bit too much
i gotta say the horse almost got me
it's slime
hell yeah
that horse is listening to bbc dance
radio
[Laughter]
i'm actually surprised that you're
actually dying at almost everything no
i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm not
not laughing at all i think you are all
right taco bell huh what is this
something just something all right it
make me laugh all right it makes me do a
funny nose exhale so i show it to you
all right thanks so much for having me
yep see you later see ya
finally
nice
this is that this is too close to home
for me to laugh at sam i can't do this
bro i uh as a pescatarian type
i eat a lot of fake protein that makes
you go uh er air from the [ __ ] okay
again
every time i leave my friend's house i
just hold that
so hard we gotta normalize farting we
just gotta normalize it all right don't
need to be in germany is it like a
normalized thing in germany no [ __ ]
germans weirdos that's
i swear it's like a normal thing for
them like there are countries that
[ __ ] like love that [ __ ] but it's not
seen as disgusting
i don't know i remember germany was on
the list or something like that but
we're we're learning stuff here today
when we like
i like they oh you're gonna love this
one or maybe you don't hate this one you
hate six nine right no i i he's he's all
right
it's it's all love it's salty
goodness
it's not funny guys
it was already supposed to happen
[ __ ] i don't know what kind of gun that
is
all right no more laughing from now on
how many life do i have left side oh man
you're currently in like minus six right
shut up come on
i'll give you an extra life all right
like just there thanks so thank you
cheers
thank you for the several raises of my
english
nuts
[Applause]
of deets nuts
hey chris
how'd these nuts taste
are they delicious you actually held
that one down well i held it down i held
it down
i'm just confused what the [ __ ] is it
they actually named the brand of the
nuts
and i think it's a funny [ __ ] apparently
no raise for you there sign
okay you know what every time you don't
laugh the life goes back up again oh
hell yeah all right
there you go
you're gonna start paying me at the end
of this
[Music]
babe please see a psychiatrist you are
not [ __ ] warrior in 13th century
[Music]
[Applause]
i literally sent you oh this whole meme
fall there 6 a.m last night i was tired
you know when you're so tired it just
sounds so funny what was the mongols
deal huh it just sounds funny
it's just funny
funny throat singing again funny throat
sound
man
we got the donk
yeah yeah once again
that's interesting
can we can someone explain the context
of this i literally don't know the
context i just saw this clip and i was
like what is that an edit was that
serious i like
i like how we're both like fart joke
funny haha guys
i didn't laugh by the way but it was a
repulsive
shock backwards
i mean i couldn't tell i can't see you
right now okay perfect yeah yeah yeah i
can tell when you verbally laugh
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
i think all of these are like what the
[ __ ] is the context explain this to me
what
why am i laughing exactly
i read yesterday that like culturally
laughter was used just to like mock
people it wasn't used to laugh at humor
what the [ __ ]
what are we doing here now they are we
just a bunch of phonies
stop
oh this is gonna be so [ __ ] everyone's
gonna be mad at me for laughing at every
[ __ ] thing god damn they're gonna be
laughing too like these clips on fire
this feels like joe rogan's like
daydream or some [ __ ] like
actual [ __ ]
sleep deprivation
oh man
hello
i have just one question for you
are you ready
am i ready for what who's this are you
ready for this sunday night when wwe
champ john cena defends his title in the
[Music]
pay-per-view event wwe just 59.99
i'm sorry no there is not any chance in
health oh we're gonna have wrestling in
this house again but thank you again
have a good day again
hi can i speak to champ
who
champ
it's champ wait what the [ __ ] is the
context say
it's like a prank call or why did you
say
wrestling again because she's got like
standard this call like several times
like the whole like oh my god and she's
like what
is it
[Music]
like that's the problem with all these
clips like that download there's no
content
that's pretty good but i didn't lie all
right let the record show no laugh
this is boomer's dialogue
all right illegal drugs you do in your
garage
oh great the skyrim dialogue no there's
no illegals
[Music]
that's a good one that's a good one
that's a good one i love the scary meme
did she come from hello there
hello
yeah
i thought he was gone this one didn't
make me laugh too much but i felt like
it would make you laugh we are going to
washington dc
and we are going to drain
[Music]
hell yeah
oh yeah
i knew trump was train gang yeah
four more years of drain let's go
[Laughter]
all right i'm taking that life out from
you right yeah dude i'm canceled for
this come on come on
chance you fall
so visible
one
what's someone
from
near
no
this is funny because i can relate to
this british names makes no [ __ ]
sense sometimes yeah but how could you
miss that hard
nah
understandable dude how would you say
this all right that's the share what the
[ __ ] happened to all the syllables
where the [ __ ] did they go
listen look i completely agree right
english is such a dumb language because
it's like there's exceptions to the rule
and it just doesn't make sense how do
you say this new key no it's new yeah
it's no it's
no it's not queen where's where's the k
where's the e where's the
dude my neighbors asked me like where
are you going i was like oh glow chester
shire they're like what what
[ __ ] you saying
i told it's just the language it's just
full of exceptions it's so dog [ __ ] i
get it i can't even hate but like at
least you tried to say it [ __ ]
mumble rap
[Laughter]
no this is how you sound saying it again
the new kitty i mean maybe i was like
pissed drunk maybe i'd sound like that
leave me
just you fall
it says if you try to say sheffield in
one syllable
[Laughter]
goddammit this is like the worst your
life you lose
this is the best deal after this only
you're laughing i'm laughing i guarantee
you the fans are yeah yeah yeah yeah
we'll see we'll see no more laughter
after this okay this one's for you by
the way all right
[Music]
hey
hey what
what
what did i just watch explain explain
the funny funny
explain the pointing now restart it
restart it
i saw this on my
page for you page and i was just dying i
was like oh my god i need to say this to
show this to physics but i never sent it
to you
el primo federica
that's a hard that's a hard one his head
though that is [ __ ] good haircut i'll
get that i'm gonna do that i'll do it
frederica
hell yeah all right a little confused
it's not gonna lie but yeah
i get it
it's weird but you see yourself
what would be your version name
oh god mexican slime i want to see that
oh god
[Applause]
oh no no i know
[Music]
no way he's actually really good
damn
i do wonder what he's doing during that
day yeah right
ah dude this could be like a really deep
emotional
sad cringe
hilarious meme if you added in his clips
like in between i mean just eating a
bunch of [ __ ] just i'm crying
this is ninja
[Applause]
[Laughter]
just the ultimate
oh man what's worse taking this [ __ ] no
you know this is worse what the [ __ ] why
does he remind my ninja so much i don't
know it's just a low quality camera very
typical
yeah wait no no ikea memes i told you
bro
when he sees me taking a massive
mudslide
in the display
for the love of god
please
damn
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean
yes all right come on that i i i laughed
a little bit but it doesn't get yeah it
was it was a mid laugh like i'm not i'm
not going to hold that against you
i've genuinely lost count of how many
lives you got so like it's so good it's
so good i'll just wait to the end but if
you laugh at the last meme it's an l
where is my avocado what did i do what
did he do
i can't find an avocado no
no avocado will sponsor me that's
unfortunate first strawberry
strawberries
what the [ __ ]
i forgot to take the green stuff off
it's so easy to do
it's so easy you don't cut it off
blooper eyes
[Music]
let's put cherries
or should i say chair
just stick with cherries
pineapple
instead of orange juice mango greens
what the [ __ ] did you make me watch
science
god damn it
give me weird like beldelphine vibes i
don't understand
like weird humor i was just laughing at
the guy crying because it's just like
how i'd feel if i was forced to watch
that [ __ ]
customer service did some when they
dropped this one all right
you've heard this shortly right
no
i might know everyone has heard this oh
oh [ __ ] hey
hell yeah i'll wait
[ __ ] yeah
oh
what how do you know
[Music]
[Applause]
no i get the stupid [ __ ] classic
music and yeah and i'm like can you just
leave it quiet please right
that's so much better i don't know if
i'm like the only person that's heard
this i know all my friends are like i've
never heard this like who did your car
who did you call this is like i don't
know it's like i don't know these like
dodgy places where they have like the
default sound machine and this is like
the default song no [ __ ] way it is
that's why it's such a meme this is like
the indian scam thing when they want you
to hold they'll distract you with a good
jam
yeah it's genius
mcdonald's what can i get you today yes
can i get one fellaio fish yes um let me
get a manager for you
uh okay
hey chris
yeah what's up can you take this order i
think i'm gonna throw up chris i'm the
manager i'll be finishing your order
your order was the one filet-o-fish
hello
sorry i didn't hear you say that one
more time no you good um i got the
philly
this is so offensive all right some
people say are pescatarian and they want
this is literally the only reason why i
said it
the fact that you're pescatarian like
the filet of fish even i wouldn't know
are they hey what the [ __ ] that's dog
[ __ ] is it even a thing mcdonald's yeah
they have it i i thought about that
randomly like who the [ __ ] yeah yeah
why the [ __ ] is that on their menu
as you said pescatarians you know it's
like ah pescatarian
on a regular basis
in the hope that we go back to you and
me ever believing this an imposter among
us
yeah that's the best one
[ __ ]
yeah
why is it still funny like i still see
them [ __ ] showing up like it's old
ass [ __ ] mean
jesus christ that's all it takes that's
[Music]
so dumb
jesus christ
actually mad at myself jesus
he spit all this fire and then
just ruined yeah exactly exactly like
buzzwords
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] what is
this
read the caption
yeah but what what is it
this is something you experienced
i know no that is just funny it's just
mom can we leave the beach now
the puerto ricans took out you got a
problem with puerto ricans no i don't
know i don't know
why can't they take out their bluetooth
speakers because this shit's playing
it's [ __ ]
i got no quarrels with you puerto ricans
but your music [ __ ] stuff
okay well let's just do a couple more
that's me laughing at the k cycling
when someone says among us that's just
like yeah yeah
this guy's still amazing
first name
[ __ ] oh matt my apologies how can i help
you so spot on dude
oh wow
could you excuse me for just one moment
yes thank you thank you man
everything yeah
one thing i can tell you is that tilly
should have gone to [ __ ] specs
i've actually seen it before but it's so
spot on
[Laughter]
thank you for hosting this you laugh you
lose congratulations
you get a raise hell yeah oh yeah well
done you deserve it oh man should we do
a part two at some point i guess so
let's do it we have way more clips how
about we get like 500k likes yeah oh
dude let's do an actual lego let's do it
500k likes for part two
it's not [ __ ] way of getting 500k
dude now you will you
do 300k then
300k
likes all you got to do
yeah let's start oh yeah check outside
check out i don't do any youtube or
twitter or whatever so i don't care all
right i'll be here do you do
i'll be nothing what do you do say
i literally do nothing you just added my
videos all day i literally edit your
videos all day and then i go on like
youtube and then i [ __ ] just find
these dumbass and cry
this is your way of coping
i mean maybe a bit of drink at times
hell yeah but that's about it all right
well thanks for doing this i appreciate
it no worries man appreciate it
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers are
emotions memes our emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this